Do you all want to know
what my favorite word is?
(Laughter)
It's the F word.
(Audience: Yeah!)
Some people think it's a little dirty.
Others really like to throw it around.
Oh, y’all thought I meant “fuck”?
(Laughter)
No, no, no, no, no.
My favorite word is “fandom.”
This talk is about fandom
and how fandom can enrich your life
and build a community of people
that you might not have
always talked to, right?
But I'm sure when you all think of fandom,
y'all think nerds and cosplay
and fan fiction and neck beards
and people in dark basements and stuff.
And all that is true.
(Laughter)
But you also probably think
about America's ass.
(Laughter)
I do.
(Laughter and cheers)
And yes, fandom is all of this stuff,
but it is actually a community
of people that share a passion.
Fandom is a community of people
that share a passion.
Right?
But like all things,
a there's a spectrum, right?
You have your casual fans,
your fans, your hardcore fans,
and then you have your fanatics.
And it can get really ugly,
just like that ugly thing.
Every time I see it, I run scared.
Sorry to all my Phillies fans,
it's ugly, right?
But I want to talk about the difference
between being a fan
and being a fanatic, right?
Fans want to bring in joy.
They want to share stuff
as much as possible with you, right?
Fanatics are --
And I know I watched Obi-Wan last night,
so "Star Wars" is on the brain --
But fanatics are those "Star Wars" fans
that chased two grown women
off of the internet
because they gave the Millennium
Falcon to a girl, right.
They weren't happy about that.
Those are fanatics.
We want to be fans.
We don't want to be fanatics, right?
Because fans create worlds.
Once the story is over,
once the movie is done,
they want to keep it going.
So they start to create cosplay,
fan fiction, video games.
I mean, I myself have a lot
of feelings and fandoms,
so I have a newsletter that I write
whenever I remember to write it.
(Laughter)
And also, because we're friends here,
I cosplay.
(Laughter)
I'm not new to this,
I'm true to this, right.
I wanted to still still engage
with all of the worlds that I love,
even though the movie was over.
Fans aren't gatekeepers.
Y'all can clap.
(Applause)
We all have that friend
that watches us watch a movie
because they want us to like
the same part that they like.
(Laughter)
That is a fan.
Fanatics are those people who quiz me
when I come into a comic book store
thinking because I look like this,
that I can't know about comics, right?
And fans learn life lessons from some
of the nerdiest places, right?
So for a quick example, how many
Blazers fans are here?
(Cheers and applause)
Right.
Y'all are really patient people, I'm sure.
(Laughter)
Y'all will continue to be patient.
With that number seven pick,
y’all got, sucks for y’all.
(Laughter)
Or if you were an Oregon women's
Ducks fan, which we all should be --
(Cheers and applause)
You probably understand
the importance of women in power,
the value of women in sports
and you're probably just
overall a much better person.
(Laughter)
Because fandom when harnessed is greater
than any box office number.
Right, fandom when harnessed is greater
You meet people who you might have not
necessarily always talk to, right?
You learn from so many different people
and you learn a lot of things
from these things that you love so much.
Whether or not you realize it, right?
Think about what you put
on your locker when you were a teenager
or in your three-ring binder
or even on your phone
background right now.
Something somewhere has inspired you
or guided you along this journey
called life, right?
So I'm going to give you all ten things --
I have a lot of fandoms,
I have a lot of them,
but I'm going to give you ten things
that my fandoms have taught me.
Number one, Storm from the "X-Men,"
y'all should be clapping right now.
(Applause and cheers)
She is the leader of the X-Men.
As a young Black girl seeing this tall,
beautiful Black woman
with all this white hair
and a very operatic voice leading the way,
it was very impactful
for a Fox Kids Saturday morning.
That's my son.
(Applause and laughter)
“Star Wars” taught me that my world
can be as big as a galaxy far, far away.
Whether that is real or fake.
My world can be much bigger than just
the six blocks that I call my home.
Wonder Woman --
(Cheers and applause)
Taught me that my body at any sculpt,
at any shape is beautiful, right?
Wonder Woman spent her entire life --
Y'all can clap.
(Applause)
Wonder Woman spent
her entire life training for battle.
She was not going to be a size zero.
She was going to have
quadriceps and deltoids.
I learned that word
a couple of weeks ago, deltoid.
(Laughter)
And she was going to look strong
and look beautiful while doing it.
Alright, the fourth one.
(Cheers and applause)
Venus and Serena,
as any Black girl, specifically --
We were forced to watch them,
whether or not we liked tennis or not.
(Laughter)
It's also because it came on cable
so you didn't have to, like, look for it.
But my North Star as a big sister
has always been these two.
Because when the world was against them,
they always had each other.
So whether or not I am being
a good sister in the moment,
that is what I always look towards.
(Applause)
All right.
Sneakers taught me the importance
of quality and detail, and nerds --
Sneaker heads, you all are nerds.
Nobody cares about quality leather
from 1987 to 2022 except y'all.
Y'all need to just accept it.
(Laughter)
"Harry Potter" fan fiction --
(Cheers and applause)
Taught me that I could write
myself into any story.
Those books are about this big
and Black people
had about what, eight words?
(Laughter)
So I wanted to fill in those gaps
and I was very good at it too.
Also wrote some smut,
you can look for that later.
(Laughter)
“Sailor Moon” ...
(Cheers and applause)
Taught me the power of female friendships.
That's it.
(Applause)
And now, this isn't really a lesson,
but my father is a massive nerd
and he would see me glomming on
to these superheroes, Storm,
and he would be like,
"Well, what about Black Panther?
What about Luke Cage?
What about Misty Knight?"
And in doing that,
he was trying to teach me, yes,
you can love everything that is current,
but you have to know about your past.
And so showing me all of these Black
superheroes from the '70s,
from the '60s,
kind of led me through life.
And now I'm a nerd here talking to you
all here, so blame him.
Boy bands.
(Applause)
B2K specifically, taught me
to scream really loud.
(Laughter)
Then Chyna ...
(Cheers and applause)
Taught me that I can be
the ninth wonder of the world,
that I can stand in a ring
or an office room
or here on this red carpet
and take command, right?
Because in a lot of rooms,
I will probably be the only woman.
I will probably be the only Black person.
I'm for damn sure probably
going to be the only Black woman.
So people are going to look at me anyway.
I should have something to say.
I should be able to take center stage.
(Applause)
So listen, don't be afraid of the F word.
Because when you love
what you love out loud,
that is audacious.
When you love what you love
unapologetically,
it is beautiful.
All right, so fuck it, y'all, be a fan.
(Cheers and applause)